I'm not a demon see just a guy here to
rescue these dragons a part of what
makes these movies real special is how
these movies sound we have a pretty
amazing cast of characters it's this
really kind of special kaleidoscope of
voices that you wouldn't necessarily
always think would be together enough
jabbering let's get to work
when I started recording asteroids voice
I had very little experience in
voiceover it's not the same thing as
acting in front of a camera at all it's
it's a different skill I'm not a stand
around and talk kind of girl I love
voice work and this is the real pinnacle
of voice work as a doctor smartest
dragon hunter I ever met well thanks to
me of course I enjoy hearing myself more
than I like looking at myself it's fun
here in my voice you know it's fun
trying to make children laugh there's a
little more character and energy to it
toothless I love that everyone has their
own approach to their characters but
they all do so with ownership and
authenticity
[Music]